so let's talk about escorting so you uh
wrote about escorting your blog post s
Corning was good for me
um
how did you get into escorting I was
working at like a I'd quit camming
because I was burned out and I was like
trying to work at a friend's startup and
it was
hard for me I don't it's difficult for
me to work on projects that are not my
projects uh
and so I was like hey [__] it like I
want to go back to sex work I want to
make more money but I don't want to cam
anymore because I'm burned out so I'm
like well let's try I have a friend
who's an escort I'm like let's try that
and so we had a call she'd like outlined
the basics for me and then I just put up
some ads and started working what's the
basics of us corny how's that work the
base if you want to get started
escorting so just yeah
uh are you gonna wanted to get some nice
photos so you probably won't have those
first of all you you assumed I haven't
done it before have you yeah well you
know uh Recreation I would like to do
professionally I suppose so if I wanted
to do it if I wanted to do it if I
really really want to step up my game
how would I do it
yeah well you got the whole tutorial
recreational
I just
okay okay not meaning like like
you know like selling products on Etsy
versus
doing a startup
yeah uh well I mean escort is kind of
also selling products on Etsy you know
like but selling a lot of products high
volume
yeah like like yeah small handcrafted
Artisan Dolls yeah
was this Mass manufacturer
okay
I just feel like I haven't been getting
you know I've been undervaluating my
services and I would like to really step
up I think you could really just like
grease some marketing gears and
Beach yeah I mean it's just some of this
is marketing so like how I guess I want
to like know is it similar to camming in
that way like is it
um you're basically advertising yourself
and you're
uh like the marketing the all the
creativity that you mentioned before all
of that yeah I found escorting to be
pretty easy because uh escorting is not
like highly competitive for example
camming is highly competitive because
like the Strat the thing that I outlined
before you know the amount of money that
you make determines your ranking and you
can also go and see other girls you can
see what they're doing so if a girl
figures an incredible strategy for
making money it's like two seconds
before that strategy per little threats
into everybody else so it's very fast
paced and like really tough with
escorting you don't get to see what
other girls are doing you can look at
their websites but like you don't know
what they're doing with clients at all
you can look at their rates but you
don't know what their volume is so you
don't actually know what is successful
and what isn't very much
um so I think there's much less uh like
evolution of marketing through the
through this process and so I came in
with like my aggressive marketing skills
for being a cam girl I think that really
helped I did very well as an escort I
came in like made a fantastic website
and I knew how to do the ads right and
and what was the finding people I guess
is also like finding the right kind of
customer
oh the right kind of client I got like
in a lot of trouble for this recently in
the sex workers sphere because I said
that if you raise prices you're more
likely to encounter clients that aren't
going to abuse you
like it's safer yeah uh they did not
they said that I was being classist you
know implying that poor people are more
violent but to be fair if you're a guy
and you want to be violent towards a
woman you're probably not gonna be
paying a lot of money you're probably
gonna need like you're the kind of
person likely who's going to haggle a
lot because you don't respect her yeah
but anyway that aside it's a little pet
peeve for me
um yeah I just I started charging 800 an
hour and then pretty rapidly raised it
to 1200 and then a while after that
wasted to 1400. well the interesting
thing you mentioned in my extensive
research
um you used to do 1200 to 1400 an hour
and then you said that you're thinking
of jumping back in at a rate of 2400
the first hour yeah and I think 900 each
successful hour that's interesting
that's like that's that I mean to me
that's really interesting like the for
like why it's like the first hour yeah
oh it's just because uh it depends on
how you want to incentivize like the
amount of hours so if you have to pay a
lot for the first star but not very much
for the success if you're more likely to
buy like a longer period of time and
usually I find that clients who buy a
longer period of time are nicer to you I
don't have like a great theory for why
that is but there's more likely like
taking dinner and get to know you first
and I just enjoy that a lot more I enjoy
like
like knowing who I'm gonna have sex with
like a date you know yeah so it
incentivize the the long form date
Dynamic versus like uh not that's really
interesting
that's so interesting how does money
change the dynamic just basic human
Dynamic of interacting for free versus
for money like I think about that a lot
because like just talking to rich people
it's like you usually get paid for your
time and you're doing this for free like
what uh
like what's the difference is there a
difference really or no
so when I was doing it full time it was
my only source of income
it changed quite a lot because I was
really incentivized to have repeat
customers so I'm like okay if I'm my
primary interaction with you is to like
have you hire me again I will do
whatever that takes to make that happen
and so if I have to like laugh at jokes
that I find funny or like to be like
more adoring of your penis than I
actually genuinely feel like that's what
I'm going to express yeah um and
obviously it's to some degree like
titrated you know like I it's unpleasant
to force yourself to like something that
you don't so like I would actually like
not see clients again that I didn't want
to but it's just some degree there was a
sort of self-suppression going on which
I think is this the way it works in any
sort of customer service job like you
want the customer to leave happy so you
just make sure that you are happy the
whole time and you're like ah really
enjoying the other person but uh so
recently when I've like kind of dabbled
in it since baking money for through
other means
um where I don't need the money it's
more like a fun side thing that like it
that I'm like I said it's fulfilling the
role of casual sex for me so like I
don't have to do it this is not my
primary job I just want sort of a good
excuse to like have sex with somebody
and the money is like a great filter for
that and so in that case that's
interesting so the money is there but
yeah okay the money is basically a
filter for somebody who's taking this
interaction seriously yeah it also so
there's an interesting like
psychological thing where I have
difficulty having casual sex with
somebody because some part of my brain
which I assume is like quite female is
doing some evaluation of status and
whether or not this is going to damage
my reputation by having sex with them so
like if you found out that I went and
like had random sex with like a homeless
man you might be like wow that says
something about Ayla like maybe she's
you know trashy or she just has no
standards for who she's gonna [__] but
if and so some part of me is continually
anxious I'm like does this mean I have
no standards if I decide to have casual
sex with you like what are people going
to think uh and so if you introduce
money it takes away that anxiety I don't
have to worry about it because it's like
oh of course Ayla would have sex with
that person they paid her like this is
not an indication of the kind of mate
that she can get this is just an
indication of like a business
transaction and this allows me to enjoy
casual sex so much more when somebody
pays me for it to the degree that like I
almost view it as Kink and so it's like
so I'm using it sort of to replace
casual sex now like occasionally I'm
like you know like pay me a little bit
to erase the anxiety and I'll like have
a fun fun time in case you see like
dinner like that or something like that
if the person pays for dinner or like
it's like it's all just if any money's
involved if it's a kink then you could
just like use it and you
you buys a coffee at a Starbucks it's
like all right great but it has to be
plausible like you have to like trick my
brain into like having it actually be
incentivizing for me
like China or something yeah like oh the
homeless man bought me a coffee and then
I sucked this dick like that's not cool
all right so no shade of homeless man by
the way like I've been friends with a
lot of them I'm just using like some
sort of stereotype of yeah right now so
like it has to be plausible where you
could trick your mind interesting yeah I
mean yeah
and so that's different so now now with
in this sort of frame I am still like
I'm accepting money but still much more
expressive of my actual preferences so
like I before when I would start
escorting full-time I was suppressive
and now I'm like you know like I'm doing
this for me so we're going to make sure
that I have a good time and so I'm much
more demanding
and then you're having more fun because
you're not pretending exactly laughing
at a joke or something like that that
sounds terrible
sounds like I mean that's but it's also
like social I mean I guess I I would
would I do that like when you first meet
people like strangers and so on there's
some aspect of like
niceties but like I don't know intimacy
like real intimacy requires like getting
past the nice cities like laughing at
somebody's joke when it's not funny
feels like anti-intimacy yeah
yeah any jokes automatically if
interesting because like I don't mean to
I'm not trying to be fake but like if
I'm in a group of people and somebody
makes a joke and everybody laughs I
laugh even before I'm checking within
myself like do I genuinely enjoy this
joke yeah so it's like I don't know like
the degree that I am sort of just like a
result of social programming in all
cases that like when I'm with a client
back when I was doing it full time like
it doesn't feel significantly different
it just felt like a different version of
myself
yeah that's true yeah to that degree to
the degree you don't feel like you're
going against yeah your your nature yeah
yeah it was very rare that I actually
felt like I was
against my nature
um what about the market of how much to
charge
say 20 2400 like how transparent is that
market is there like a market like how
much can you sell when you're charging
that much yeah no like what what are the
competitors like if this oh yeah like
what do are you distinctly what because
you said it's uh a lot of is a is a bit
more shrouded a mystery I guess a more
confidential like do you have some
transparency to the the market what the
competitors are so a survey of escorts
only like 130 I'm trying to remember and
the median was around like 400 300 I
think an hour oh wow something like that
with a very long tail at the top end if
I'm trying to remember what the I also
asked him the amount that I could
calculate the amount they made per month
I think it was like six or seven
thousand dollars a month I need to
double check that one but I charge 50
bucks an hour you charge 50 bucks an
hour you should raise your rates yeah I
believe I get a really shitty [__]
um all right but usually the the rates
are around like if you want a median
escort in a big city it's usually four
days a city so the urban sorry four four
to six hundred I'm in a big city but
like smaller cities you charge the rates
go lower
um
that's so fascinating what's like the
most you've ever seen somebody charge
uh
um I I think I am you're like the
but at this point it's because I'm post
work like I can I can just put it in the
same number there's like in like does
the fact that you're sort of
like a sexuality expert like uh
researcher and so on like your mind is
fascinating as well and you're a bit of
a celebrity there's that play into it
yeah uh do you feel the celebrity no
like yeah with people yeah absolutely
usually if people are interested in
hanging out with me it's because of that
um
but that's that's different like I think
besides the like the the fun part like
the this is a kink as opposed to this is
a job like with this as a job usually
the high end is closer to two thousand
an hour like the very high end